good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a beautiful
Monday here in New York City following a
beautiful weekend here in New York City
and I'm here with Claude high and earn
hey Jax I'm doing good feeling all right
for this Monday morning I hope everyone
had a fabulous weekend I am just you
know chugging along trying to stay
mentally stable which is proving to be
really hard yeah it was definitely a
challenge this weekend because it was so
beautiful
Friday was one of my worst days mentally
in quarantine I just I don't know what
to call it other than a complete and
utter mental breakdown um but I had a
decent weekend Saturday I got up and out
Zack and I went all the way down to the
West Village we walked so much like my
pedometer on my phone was like tweaking
out like what is she doing um so that
was good my legs were broken and
yesterday I was able to lay out for a
while while I read I got a sunburn can
you see oh oh I got a sunburn damn oh I
got that vitamin D which I've been
reading is so important right now it is
vitamin D pills actually because I have
no access to the Sun I think I'm sure
that that's good but direct sunshine is
always great and so I was glad that I
was able to get some Sun made it through
another weekend in the Q but as we get
into spring summer like it's just gonna
get harder and harder to not be outside
yeah and I'm actually curious if
everyone at home is struggling so much
seriously like with their mental health
like I never really thought I was one of
those people who like was prone to such
like anxiety and mood swings and like
last night was a real I was just like
feeling so low like all day and then
before I went to bed it like switched on
to this high that was like so
unnaturally I was like dancing and
singing around my room and it really
just made me think like that I'm going
I'm going crazy like I feel like after
quarantine or I should probably start
during quarantine like I'm definitely
going to see like a licensed therapist
because I'm having such bad anxiety such
crazy mood swings like I don't know if
that's normal just because I'm stuck
inside my house because I don't remember
feeling this way when life was back to
normal
but like I'm really like not okay no I
completely agree
um and then I also start to get anxiety
about the show because I'm like am I
being too not okay on the show and then
I started having side of me at
everything that I said and like that I
just need to like pull my mask on
tighter you know totally like shut the
[ __ ] up yeah yeah like no I'm good it's
great I love Guardino totally like and I
feel like I don't know I know we're
supposed to be like positive and stuff
and I feel like for the most part like
the show is like a nice hour a day we're
really funny and whatever but sometimes
like I just wake up and I feel so down
yeah I think that's normal because
nothing about this is normal and you're
not expected to be great all the time I
will say the beginning of the week's in
terms of the show are always more upbeat
for me by the end of the week like I am
just in a dark place so today I feel
light and Sprite and um and okay and we
actually have a lot to talk about today
I watched so much TV this weekend i
watch everything that I had said that I
would I watched dead to me I finished
dead to me I watched Hollywood
I started money high season four I read
the book for the redheads and that's
about it but that's a lot oh I read a
book too this weekend I'm really on to
like a reading kick that's always how it
happens for me like it's in spurts and
it's really only books by celebrities
because that's my genre of choice but I
read Gary janetti's book and it is just
so funny and so I mean he's a writer
like at heart so I don't like I expected
I had high expectations and they really
met them it was so funny and like it was
more short essays and it was really like
snackable which is you know what I love
to do snack and I really enjoyed it like
I was hysterically laughing at so many
things like him taking the qe2 home from
his program in London like thinking that
was cool but it's actually a really
weird thing to do when they would sing
happy birthday at the restaurant like
you don't understand how that spoke to
my soul like I don't I think I couldn't
be a waiter or waitress because I could
not galvanize people to sing happy
birthday for my table no totally it was
just it was really well done and I
enjoyed it a lot so Jessica Simpson's is
still you know on the back burner but if
I find something shorter before that I
will start it but if not I'll just do
Jessica Simpson's next
I just know that like everything you're
describing to me your symptoms like if I
were a doctor I would tell you to read
Jessica Simpson's book like that yet I
would prescribe well I'm actually quite
busy today so I don't think I'll start
reading today because we are recording a
patron episode and then I'm recording
another patron episode with Margot which
is like a Taylor Swift themed episode
which I'm really excited about and then
I have um I have to catch up and finally
all caught up to the new season of drag
race the one that's airing right now and
there's so much drama I like I'll tell
you all about it in the TV account
segment so I'm excited about that also
I'm also excited um
because yesterday Ben and I drove down
to Times Square which is somewhere I
normally wouldn't go um but there was
this spotted by campaign that they asked
me to be a part of them basically just
like submit a picture and like a quote
and it was my impression that it was
like an Instagram campaign like I didn't
really think much of it and then they
sent me like this picture you're on the
billboard in Times Square and I'm like
excuse me
so me and Ben took men I got so many
questions like you have a car you rented
a car like so many questions we use
Ben's parents but like I don't get it
what's the problem regardless either no
they were just like it wasn't people
weren't like trying to cancel me they
were just genuinely like shook they're
like you have that car it's like when
you share so much about your life and
then people find out something but they
didn't they feel betrayed you know I
feel like we talking about Ben's car
before though
I mean it's Ben's parents car they let
us use it whenever they want and they
haven't used it in months because
they're quarantined in the city as well
but we just went and picked it up and
drove down to Times Square um of course
my luck would be you know getting on a
billboard when people aren't allowed to
leave the house so that's just like my
life that's my career kind of in it in a
metaphor you know yeah
well at least you're on a billboard in
Times Square and you know what you
probably got fabulous pictures because
you didn't have like so many people
swarming about yeah no and I'm like I
got to double Park in a bus lane and
nobody said a thing about it
wow that's Claudia that's beautiful so
that was awesome thanks Spotify for
hooking it up also just a reminder I
have a comedy special coming out June
30th it's available available for
pre-order on iTunes you could tap the
link in my bio on Instagram it's called
just great screen and thank you all for
ordering it the numbers are in the early
numbers and they're looking good oh
that's so exciting I see that there's a
chairman behind you he looks beautiful
as ever
um how is he how is he doing
he's doing good he's reached the point
in quarantine where his hair is just out
of control and I've trimmed in areas
that I can like not to be gross but the
hair around his penis grows really fast
and when he pees if the hair is really
long like it just gets dirty it's a
place you want it's like pubes that you
want to keep it clean um but I'm so
nervous to like put scissors near his
penis so I've been doing very small like
ear trims belly trims but it's gotten to
a place that I can no longer handle and
of course his weekly bi-weekly groomer
is not tubing appointment so I don't
know what I'm gonna do I'm ready to like
shave him with a razor like the one that
been use is like a buzz cut okay well
just let it grow like this is the like
this is the longest field his hair will
ever be at least you know let him see
how how long he can grow it yes I mean I
don't know where my mental health would
be if I wasn't like quarantined with CEO
and I was thinking a lot over the
weekend like of course I'm so excited to
get back to normal life but I'm
obviously gonna have to leave Theo at
home alone like he hasn't been alone in
three months and I'm like I'm having a
lot of separation anxiety even though
like for New Yorkers a quarantine
doesn't even like seem to be really even
close to being over but I'm thinking
about that moment when I have to leave
him at home yeah
it'll be okay I think I'd then like he's
gonna need some alone time he has some
things like he hasn't been alone at all
like he can't go into the bathroom and
lock the door and just like have a
moment for himself and so I think he
said I'm much looking forward to that
like solid diamond I guess I mean that
hurts my heart to think that he's like
trying to get away from me but um it's
okay he's he's feeling he's feeling got
his spirits are high and he's like I
think he's feeling this like weight and
this burden on his shoulders because so
much of my sanity Ben sanity your sanity
that relies on the well-being
he just wants he's soaking up all of our
emotions and it's in him to carry he
needs to be the best version of himself
which um is not always easy totally I'm
just like loving this sunburn because
even though I'm so anti sunburned and
like I if I had usually had a summer and
like I would never be showing you guys
but it's just a reminder that I Jackie I
was in the Sun like no it's a battle
scar no it's like I'm just wearing it
with pride like I'm so excited that I
have a son Carson not a sensation it's a
badge of honor it's ya know truly I'm
just
um even though it's like catchy and not
now it's beautiful
it's beautiful Jackie that's beautiful
a lot of stuff happened over the weekend
actually so we do have a decent amount
of stories along with a great TV recap
segment oh my god I got so much for you
guys in the TV recap segment like I
finally sat down with my television oh
and I just want to say I read the
redheads book it took me all of
yesterday but so I was still able to
read it in a day even though I really
didn't plan on it we're not recording
till Wednesday so like now I have to
just try and keep it in my head but I
saw a lot of mixed reviews because
there's a lot of different characters
it's confusing which is why I chose it
like I just needed us to all level up in
terms of my book
yes exactly um and I've really liked it
I obviously have a lot of thoughts but
overall it kept me so interested and
it's an interesting story with lots of
twists in store twists and turns in a
lot of different characters I know
people found that part confusing I
didn't um but sometimes when you're
confused you just need to keep reading
and then eventually that part that you
didn't get before will make sense
afterwards so it's like generate I would
a hundred percent recommend that people
read it it's called the glass hotel and
the new episode of the redheads is
dropping on Thursday very exciting also
just a quick update in my life like this
is what my life has come to I recently
made the transition as in recently on
Friday from the Amazon fire stick to the
Apple TV and I was an early adapter to
the Apple fire stick I have I mean the
Amazon fire stick I'd like three in my
house um and it was just like one day it
stopped working like it is the slowest
piece of [ __ ] ever but at the end of the
day gets the job done even though you'll
be watching Hulu and then it'll be like
sorry we decided to stop working and
like you want to open hello cool do you
have 30 minutes to spare it's just like
not a good thing um but it's like so
cheap and I just I don't know I got
comfortable with it but I finally made
the splurge on an Apple TV in my bedroom
and wow what if what a superior platform
like the way it integrates with your
phone when you want to type something
all of a sudden this app comes out that
you didn't even know it's like hey you
want to type instead of use this remote
and it's just fabulous the remote is
really small and keeps getting lost my
blanket and in fact they have to charge
it isn't a weighing but I'm so much
happier with the with the box
um one you're preaching to the choir to
get us a cover for your remote that's
like a grip that way doesn't start like
slide everywhere it's a game changer
three
you need to charge it once a year like
Oh whatever it never needs charging
every once in a while my thing's not
working like maybe it needs to be
charged I mean no if that's the problem
but so I charge it Oh
also I gave myself a manicure this
weekend I think it's been my most
favorite manicure in the queue so far
check it out it's a different snow I
feel like my hands were just like
skittles like I'm loving it and it's
really improving look at these hands
don't look at mine um so I'm feeling
really great about that I'm so happy for
you okay so I think it's time you two
shut right in you know no time like the
present right Oh sis you're preaching to
the choir there's no time like the
present to get into the fast eye stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and that's true Jax but if you would
just allow me one minute to let the
toasters know that today's episode is
brought to you by mazury mazury makes
fine jewelry for every day it's fairly
priced handcrafted and ethically sourced
Missouri's mission is fine jewelry for
my damn self we may be going nowhere but
we're definitely getting dressed Jewelry
is one of the easiest ways to upgrade
your work from home look especially
shoulders up think 14 karat solid gold
staples they're light as air hoops
barely there chains and everyday
diamonds they also have bolder pieces
like chunky chains ring stacks you could
take a trip to Paris with their
croissant edition and experiment with
sterling silver and white gold pieces
their new items drop every Monday all
year long so if you're working from home
so is Missouri you can book a digital
one-on-one appointment and live chat
with a stylist get answers to all your
burning questions like how can i style
this can I mix metals what's my ring
size and so much more wherever you are
Missouri stylists are here to help and
you can get free shipping on US and
Canada orders plus easy returns and a
two-year warranty head to Missouri comm
slash totes for 10% off your first order
that's MJ URI Stockholm slash totes for
10% off your first order
we love wearing Missouri especially on
the toast it really elevates you know a
pantless look and if you're taking zoom
calls all day and you want to impress
that cutie from HR get yourself a dainty
chain or keep hearing that's exactly
what I need today I'm so rth that I
didn't get my major yet before this
because like now I'm realizing like
that's what
what is missing to complement your
sunburn for sure exactly to just bring
it out and like radiate Sun totally okay
cool um okay our first story is the big
story of the day Bachelorette Hannah
brown apologizes after saying the N word
on Instagram quote there is no excuse so
here's the story Hannah Brown has issued
an apology for saying a racial slur
on social media during a since expired
Instagram live video she wrote I owe you
all a major apology there's no excuse
and I will not justify what I said I
have read your messages and seen the
hurt I caused I own it all I am terribly
sorry I know that whether in public or
private this language is unacceptable I
promise to do better she found herself
in hot water on Saturday night when she
repeated the n-word while singing the
lyrics to the babies hit single rock
star fans watching along caught the
moment immediately confronting her in
the comments and she said I did a
seemingly surprised according to the
clips from the live she said I'm so
sorry no I was singing I'm so sorry I
really don't think I said that word I
don't think I said that word but I'm
like oh god she continued I'd never used
that word I'd never call anybody that we
don't say that word so if you've seen
the video but she probably has by now
um sheep out like she realizes it in the
video and she's like giggling and
blaming it on her brother is her brother
pathetic yeah and then her poor friend
Brooke like to me
what's so egregious about this whole
thing is her reaction in the video and
then her apology like both of which
we're not sufficient and it's not on me
to demand an apology from her because
I'm not black but like I just see this
as a person who comments on canceled
culture and this is just not the way to
do it yeah um a lot there's been a lot
of conversation about this and I think
actually something I'm gonna say
positive that's come out of this is
Rachael Lindsey went on the Instagram
live yesterday um really just doing an
explainer 100 101 as to why white people
can't use this word say this word or
even sing this word and I feel like some
people some people know that you can't
sing the word but they don't get why and
she did a fabulous job of explaining it
like so articulate um to people who just
like don't understand why why people
can't sing that word if it's in
song that don't put it in the song and
like right word that word has so much
history weight and cruelty and racism
behind it and it's like the least we can
do is just not sing it he's just not and
like honestly if you don't know that by
now like what is you doing like you
cannot say that and honestly I felt
really bad for Rachel Lindsay that it's
like incumbent on her to like explain to
all these people it's like leave her
alone leave her out of this but at the
same time she's so well-spoken and she's
so wise and honestly I feel like her
video which was very very well-spoken
like might have explained to a lot of
people who don't get it like it's just a
song might have explained to them why
they can't say it so like as much as I
hate that like she bears this
responsibility she did a really good job
she did a really good job and I feel
like the conversation has turned in it's
turned away from Hannah Brown and more
into like can she sing it can she not
and so rachel is really speaking on that
and I feel like she did such a great job
she also went on her Instagram stories
and told everyone to watch a video and
also said at the end of the day why are
you fighting so hard to be able to say
this word yeah and that's that on that
yeah and also to me what was so
interesting about Rachel Lindsay of it
all was a Rachel came on and she was
like there was a million things Rachel
could have done when when speaking about
this but she said she took the route of
like instead of calling someone out
giving them an opportunity to learn
DMing Hannah and she didn't say that
exactly but I got the vibe that she
dantana and maybe wanted them to go live
together and just talk about it explain
Hannah could be like I thought this and
the Rachel was like actually no it's
this um and it's divided that I got she
didn't say in specifically but I got the
vibe that she turned down the
opportunity to UM go live with Rachel or
do something with Rachel which I just
thought was such a mistake I mean Rachel
there's to be honest like there's really
no way out of a situation like this from
a PR perspective like it is bad all
around but to me Rachel Lindsay really
offered her this like wonderful
teachable moment um how to be honest
like when it comes to canceled culture
it's not always about what you do it's
also about how you react and to me like
Hannah failed on all fronts like what
she did was terrible and how she handled
it was also terrible like in Instagram
story apology that disappears in 24
hours without really I don't know I just
I
we stink like how would I want someone
who offended me to handle it and that's
not how I would want them to handle it
that story goes away in 24 hours and
that's just not to me that doesn't seem
like she really cares yeah or she just
didn't think it was as big of a deal as
it's becoming you know she thought that
it would like just like the news cycle
it would be gone in 24 hours she doesn't
need to put this on her feed forever you
know and have that be there forever um
no I totally I totally agree I didn't
get the vibe necessarily that Rachel was
gonna go live with her but I think
Rachel's point was like whatever
platform you used to convey your
offensive message you must use the same
one to apologize and make it right and
doing an Instagram story is not the same
as doing an Instagram live and she said
if you're brave enough to go on
Instagram live and use that word you
should be brave enough to apologize for
it on Instagram live and I think that's
a very fair point
Rachel Lindsey for president I totally
agree I like and it's so funny how
people in the Batchelor community and I
didn't even realize I did two like they
just turned to Rachel Lindsay in most
situations because she's so wise like
what does Rachel have to say like I
think what Rachel thinks because she's
so smart and I'm glad that she used it
as an opportunity not to be like catty
and call someone out but like for
genuine um like knowledge and just
teaching people because the amount of
people who are defending Hannah is like
disappointing to Rachel and to everyone
um and I think there was so many ways
she could have went about speaking on
this and the way that she did was just
Cheska's I totally agree um I wonder if
we'll hear from Hannah again we'll keep
you posted on that um I hope I do that
was like that is just not sufficient
yeah I would agree so I feel like that's
always kind of how it happens like you
get like a first apology and then you
get like backlash for the apology so
then you do like another bigger apology
you know yeah I mean this is just bad
yeah
no bueno it's that especially for a girl
who like aside from you know having a
called off engagement which is just like
she was you know
sweetheart victim like for a girl who
squeaky-clean like right universally
beloved from the second she stepped on
the scene like you get used to that kind
of praise and of course canceling
someone is bad but like to go from such
a high high to a very low low like that
just kids not good no it's not okay this
next story I'm so interested by it was
all the talk of the toasters last night
um
the call her daddy podcast call her
daddy podcast hosts have quote turned on
each other and insider says to page six
okay so this past weekend page six
they've been kind of following this
story they're really the only ones I
think like someone's giving them
information reported a story that Alex
and Sophia from call her daddy as we all
know they stopped doing their podcast
about five weeks ago leaving a trail
like free the fathers um also I'm
obsessed with them so I've just been
like following this and also obsessed
with like podcast news and like a fan
yell do oh they're so funny I love their
friendship I just like feel personally
invested in this story so then this
weekend it came out that Alex and Sophia
are like butting heads and that was a
twist that I did not see coming then
last night dave Portenoy dropped an
episode on the call her daddy podcast
feed explaining what's been going on
from his point of view and while like he
said no one's ever called him a liar
like he's definitely a lot of things but
he's not untruthful um so I believe what
he's saying I also think there's a lot
of like perspective in context from the
other side that we're probably not
getting yeah I also think quickly that
that's New York Post article was
probably filled with a lot of
misinformation because page six isn't
exactly known for their truth-telling
and the woman who wrote this article has
like a vendetta I remember there was
like this whole drama about a photoshoot
last year like this woman hates to call
her daddy girls so I just think it's
important to keep that in mind and I'm
obviously taking the side no matter what
of the female podcast you oh just
because that's me um but I just feel
like there's generally some truth in
this article but I definitely feel like
a lot of it is fake that's all okay well
they had a lot of like what seems what
Dave said was like truthful information
about you know Sofia's boyfriend kind of
shopping around the show wonder he
offering them a deal apparently a lot of
that was true
but I'm sure
I'm sure it's filled with things that
aren't you right so then Dave started
just giving spitting numbers and he
basically said well first of all what I
found interesting is that Alex and
Sophia were not paid the same up until
now Sophia was paid a little bit less
but Dave explained that like he found
the podcast through Alex Alex did all of
like you know the communication bringing
it to barstool as far as he knew Alex
was doing all the editing and this was
where it started to get sad for me
because like I just feel like as a
podcast you oh like you and I there are
some podcasts where it's like the host
and then the sounding board but I feel
like if you listen to their show where
you watch our YouTube videos or their
Instagram stories like even though one
of them might do a little bit more work
sometime like they are really a duo and
even like an Alex show on her own would
be good Sofia show on her own would be
good like the two of them together like
something magical happens like I feel
like it's the same thing with you and I
like there's something about our dynamic
that people just enjoy and I they have
that same thing going on so to hear the
day one weren't being compensated the
same like made me understand why maybe
later now Sophia like didn't come back
to the table and to made me realize like
that that was never a good thing for a
partnership you have to be 50/50 or it's
just like a host and then the producer
who trans in yeah and and so when their
contract with bar stool was up when
their podcasts stopped was not was not
up there so that's what I had thought
too that they were like their contract
was up they were about to renegotiate
that's what I assumed that's why I
thought maybe not recording episodes
their initial contract was three years
and they just decided that they wanted
to renegotiate because obviously the
show is so big and they wanted more
money they wanted the IP for the show
they wanted more and you know what so
Dave actually let's he said that in
every episode that they're not doing
they are losing a hundred thousand
dollars per episode so I did a little
quick math and just ad revenue alone the
show makes over five million dollars a
year yeah he told us that the final
offer that he offered Alex and Sophia
which was obviously when you listen to
it from Dave's perspective is very
generous they very much came to the
table was half a million dollar
guarantee each which is a lot of money
yeah but for a show that makes over
five million dollars a year and it's the
it's all on their backs they don't even
go into the office they probably just
send in their episode they I don't
what's a little quick math they're
making 1/5 together so they're making
1/10 separately you you want to have
like more skin and the thing that you
own I mean of course and it's two people
who run a podcast network have a
successful podcast and know a lot of the
numbers behind it their show is much
bigger than ours if they were on their
own got her oh not a part of like a
company just got a regular podcast deal
and we're selling ads and doing merch
and maybe going on tour they could each
easily be raking in five million dollars
each so I understand like being upset
like being on salary and just like
having to be and to be honest like I are
still totally gave them their start um
but I don't even really feel like their
audience is like that type of people
anymore it's like college girls and
they're like I mean I'm on tip top all
the time and they're always doing like
call her daddy stuff like it's really
reached this new group of people in this
new audience beyond the barstool huge
audience and I don't know if they could
have gotten there without it but I
understand the frustration of being like
we are sitting on a Dimond ya know and
like they exceeded all expectations bar
school has a ton of podcasts um I think
call her daddy is either number two and
probably sometimes number one when it's
it when it's a crazy titled episode you
know yeah um and so you have to know
your value and I feel like so many
people are calling them greedy and like
they should have you know you don't bite
the hand that feeds you and it like it
just makes me feel defensive like would
we be saying this if they weren't like
just to Yemen yeah they're entrepreneurs
those two men they can expect they
deserve oh my god totally and so well I
also thought that it was the end of the
contract that does change things a
little bit but for me it's like honestly
I can't say that I wouldn't do the same
yeah
I just feel like um [ __ ] what do I feel
like remember anyway um so no III heard
her date was coming from and I think
ultimately the deal that he offered them
in the end they probably should have
taken but now it has turned into like
Alex wants that deal Sofia didn't
so Alex took that deal the deal that
Dave initially offered them was each
half a million dollars fifty fifty fifty
in everything at the end of one year
they can walk away with their show which
is a great deal
yeah Alex wanted it Sophia didn't Alex
went to Dave and said like I want this
deal so she wound up with 75% of it and
now if Sophia comes back she would only
get 25% and that's that's not gonna work
no that's not gonna work maddie was like
we're gonna make me give Alex her own
show and if Sophia wants her own show
we'll give her one too but like I just
wished it I just want you need them to
talk to each other like girl I know you
all you had us like in this business
like you have each other like what you
have is so special
I don't know much about the history of
their relationship but like I can just
their friendship is so sweet so many
people just like look at them and love
the French oh they have they're so funny
to show is is magic because of the two
of them together and I understand maybe
sometimes it feels like Alex does more
work or like Sophia you know it's just
an L so the Sophia boyfriend thing was
like a lot of drama um I'm sure I'm sure
there's contentious things but in order
for it to like work the way it has it
needs to be 50/50 you guys need to have
that respect for each other and just
talk to each other stop going through
page six stop going through Sofia's
boyfriend stop going through Dave please
talk to one another because like if it's
you two against the world your podcast
will be fine no they are so strong
together and then being on different
pages which they're entitled to but they
have to like represent a strong front
because they're literally sitting like
on a gold mine like they don't even know
because they've been a part of our soul
but if they put that year in make more
money than they were making before and
then are able in a year to walk away
with their entire show and shop it
around to podcast networks like oh my
god they will be so rich like I just I
don't know what their focus is like I
already focused on money are they
focused on paying because if you broke
with some money you got to put in the
year and then get the [ __ ] out but if
they're focused on like theme I'm sure
there's a lot of benefits about being a
part of like stoolie nation like there's
tons of benefits like I totally get that
I need to know what their goals are
what's up yes yeah and now that I think
about it like I think the answer for
them can hoping that they like what they
do and they like each other like would
be to make the show work but I don't
know maybe it's Alex like going off and
doing
maybe she becomes like major I don't
know I don't know in there I also just
want to know it's like maybe it's not
even true that they're on according to
Dave like they they they're coming to
the table with different things and I
think a lot of the dissension at least
what Dave said and you have to take it
with a grain of salt is from Sofia's
boyfriend who's been acting like a
manager shopping around the show telling
Sophia what to do getting lawyers
involved um and also I think Gabe just
like has a great beginning soon because
he works for HBO Sports and they did a
documentary that was unflattering oh I
can't keep up I mean the thing is is
that while their contract wasn't up and
Dave's still offered to slightly
renegotiate like to me that's a win they
stood up for themselves they knew their
worth they got more and then they got
the opportunity at the end of the year
to take their show so to me it's like
they stood up in these sounds and they
got what they wanted Dave didn't have to
give them more money legally they have
to keep doing doing the show like he
didn't have to even communicate with
them but you know what Dave or no I
respects female entrepreneurs honestly
that's not really what it was Dave
Portnoy needs cash now to pay his
employees it during coronavirus and due
to the pandemic it actually worked in
their favor where it's like he wanted
them to just start doing episodes again
so they could get that hundred thousand
dollars per episode and he could pay his
employees so the like I don't know if
they would have ever gotten this
opportunity if there wasn't a global
crisis right now so you just gotta told
the moment you got to take the win
sometimes I just like I don't know if
anyone here is like close personal
friends with that the girls or if they
will ever catch this but all I just want
to say to them is please talk to each
other and get on the same page and you
will be okay as long as you guys are
together a united force is the most
important thing here because home girls
you are sitting on a gold mine put in a
gear put it again but also in order for
the show to work like it has been you
guys have to be 50/50 completely and if
and if one of you needs to be doing more
work give her more work or gate delegate
delegate they live together like what
they're gonna live together again after
this no they're gonna have
like oh they're quarantined separately
for now well first they were together
and then they both went home I guess
this is too much tea I mean my opinion
on this has changed because this whole
time I thought that the contract was up
and they if the contract was up they
should 100% just like take their show
somewhere else they could be making four
or five times the amount and even though
they might not be able to take the name
call her daddy let's start a new show
call me it doesn't matter
it was copy was gonna be called the
father's at wondering whatever like it
really doesn't matter I'm sure to them
it seemed like a big deal to like lose
the name of their show that they've
spent a year building but it's it's the
morning breath to point out like it
seems like a big deal and then a year in
retrospect you're like nobody cares like
you have the audience and that's all
that matters so if the contract was over
I would have said run but now I'm the
first time hearing that it wasn't over
they just demanded more money and they
ended up using the global pandemic to
their advantage and they should have
just taken that deal 50/50 and ran but
now that Alex is on board with our soil
to be is not I'm not entirely sure I
know I think they might have overplayed
their hand a little bit and and I think
in order for it like it to work like so
Alex needs to not give Sophia back that
twenty five percent that she gained and
going alone yeah or they'll just have to
separate shows and I'm really just the
cream will rise but like there's it's so
hard to do a podcast by yourself and
when you have that hot air show it's in
yeah it's impossible period but like
when you have a partner that like makes
you better makes you funnier you know
and knows your whole life story and like
it just they're magic together you got
to bring back the girls I just can't
believe that like this podcast story
became like such worldwide news it's so
exciting I was like a podcast host a
podcast network like I'm just excited
that people are excited about this you
know me too but like it makes so much
sense like this should be an even bigger
story only page six is writing about it
but like this podcast is like has broken
so many records of podcasting and like
they just these two girls with their
like welcome to select camp like are
just taking over the charts and as a
female podcast host like I'm just so
proud of them and I only want the best
for them
I want the I truly want the best for
them
yes interesante okay we'll keep you guys
posted on that story I hope we reach
resolution soon um because I think daddy
gain could really use some new episodes
in the queue totally you know um
even though this is really not the best
time for podcasts no it's a great time
to be a web show it is okay I ready for
our next story yes ma'am
Megan Fox was seen with Machine Gun
Kelly as her husband Brian Austin Green
shares a cryptic post on her birthday
the thing for this Megan Fox was spotted
driving around and picking up food in
Calabasas with rapper Machine Gun Kelly
on Friday both Fox and the rapper have
been cast in Midnight in the switchgrass
although production on the film has been
halted due to the current a virus
pandemic deadline previously reported um
this is just an editor's note from me I
think this might be the same movie that
Randall and it was working on because he
was working on a movie with Machine Gun
Kelly when it had to go and be paused so
like that would just love that
fighting reality TV tie-in a rep for
Machine Gun Kelly did not immediately
respond to people's requests for comment
one day after the outing her husband
I guess if he's still that shared a
cryptic message on social media which
coincided with Megan's birthday he said
eventually butterflies get bored sitting
on a flower for too long they start
feeling smothered it's a great big world
and they want to experience it listen
Brian Austin Green Brian Austin Green
and Megan Fox are the messiest [ __ ]
couple in Hollywood like it's always
something with them I've always thought
that they were mismatched
and I never really understood it but I
think that they have kids in for the
sake of the kids like they tried to make
it work even though that in turn made
them the messiest couple in Hollywood I
am a Machine Gun Kelly Stan I think that
he's one of the most eligible guys in
Hollywood right now and I'm living for
this pair like they look alike they're
perfect vibes their tattoos they're both
good-looking like she's a little bit of
a cougar I'm no I am so here for this as
well um I hope that like Brian Austin
Green just like get out of the way gets
out the way um so that we can properly
ship these two yes I love like on on set
romance that audiences franchise it
enhances a film enhances completely and
I am just so excited about this
potential hopefully there is definitely
something there if they're spotted
during quarantine that means they're
definitely more than just friends I have
to assume um and then I could just see
like Megan Fox hanging out with Pete
Davidson like I just see so much
potential you see it um I see it all and
I'm so excited about it
yeah me too I just thought that was like
a fun a fun new couple it's really crazy
how like celebrities and their coupledom
are just chugging along better than ever
in quarantine you know like an enormous
and then act like like really got their
start in the queue they just did not let
like the pandemic stop them from
stepping out and about um and like a lot
of couples now are just like deciding
now's the time and I'm honestly grateful
for it because gives us stuff to talk
about and totally we get new couples to
[ __ ] yes this is my ship is truly coming
in um at the yacht house whatever they
call it the dock and for the pier the
pier and it's the ships coming in and
that's that makes me really grateful
yeah I love to watch the ships come in
it's one of my favorite activities next
to his little sad news Fred Willard Best
in Show comic actor has died at the age
of 86 Fred Willard the comic actor who
delighted audiences in beloved films
like this is spinal tap and Best in Show
over his more than 50 year career died
Friday at age 86 he died of natural
causes his family confirmed okay well
this is like a Jerry Stiller you know
it's very sad but at the same time
someone had a long happy successful life
and died of natural causes like it's a
celebration of life it's all you can
hope for yeah but you know they always
say like celebrities die in threes and
it's so true
because Jerry Stiller and then yesterday
did you hear terrible story Marc Maron's
yes it was a director died because she
just recently got ill and now Fred yeah
that was a terrible story terrible but
it's they say it happens in threes I
guess I hope this is the third and final
men yeah very sad um but
Fred Willard one of my favorite
characters from Modern Family Phil's dad
and it was honestly such a perfect
casting name look they look alike yeah
they do
yeah that's great we're wishing his
family well rest in peace
okay fifth and final story is a little
big news is brought to you by stamps
calm for all of our sakes we need to
avoid crowds any way we can right now
but what if you need to go to the post
office what if you need postage to ship
out letters and packages
don't worry stamps commas here to help
with stamps are on you can print postage
on demand and skip those lines and
crowds at the post office plus you can
actually save some money but discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office is if that wasn't enough stamp
circum also offers UPS services with
discounts up to 62 percent and no UPS
residential surcharges honestly
regardless of whether or not there's a
pandemic going to the post office is a
treacherous activity and you can avoid
it during a pandemic and then hopefully
after the pandemic with stamps are calm
they bring all the services of the US
Postal Service right to your computer in
the safety and comfort of your own home
office or anywhere else you are
hunkering down whether you're a small
business sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or you're
just working from home and need to mail
something stamps.com can handle it all
with these simply use your computer to
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just leave it at your mail
carrier schedule a free package pickup
or drop it in a mailbox no human contact
is required it's that simple and with
stamps calm you can get great discounts
- like five cents off every stamp up to
62 percent UPS shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time and money and
keeping you safe in these crazy times
right now our listeners can get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast
again that's stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in toast stay safe my friends
with dance calm love it okay our fifth
and final story a little business tech
news merger news Facebook is
what's their new company giffy jiffy Oh
interesting
yes Facebook is buying gift each iffy
and that means how you send and receive
gifts gifs on the internet could change
forever the pronunciation is just still
unclear so I'm gonna say both ways no I
mean according to many scholars yes it
is it is gif yeah but according to
normal people it's jiff right and
according to me it's gift if the service
claims at more than 700 million people
see jiffy jiffy content every day and
many of those views come from some of
the Internet's most popular apps from
Apple's iMessage to tick tock and
Twitter most of which rely on get Egypt
who's API and Archives to let users
share and post gifs it's likely that at
least some of these services won't want
to have a Facebook own platform
integrated with their products moving
forward so this could mean big changes
for any non Facebook own platform that
currently had a khadija the integration
right that's like one Facebook bought
Instagram and you can no longer send
your instagrams to Twitter they would
populate as a post but now they populate
as a link and its most no anything ever
it was like one of the like whoa Dias
gain changes of all time it was a
cultural reset yeah no it was and that
was really the end of Twitter yeah I
mean to me I use Gibby jiffy um on
Twitter a lot but I really use it um on
Instagram stickers because that's how
you can upload stickers so if you're
looking for some fabulous stickers go to
Instagram and search in the jiffy jiffy
TMT toast Austria could search a million
things the morning toast we have some
fabulous new chips so we just made so
check them out check them out yeah i
mostly use kpgb on instagram stories as
well and so that probably will only get
more integrated now that facebook has
purchased them yeah Facebook is making
good moves honestly I think that give
you jiffy is a fabulous company they've
been around for a really long time like
when I was interning at like hey Tim it
was such a big part of your job and its
really become as like huge database and
made like Jeff culture a sitting totally
I'm happy for the people that get BJP
who are you know getting a buyout and
it's very exciting for everyone I think
this is a great move my like goal is
just to get bought out like I just love
like an easy
hey you know no I know it's like I keep
trying to invent stuff I'm like more
it's a scrunchie wrapped around aquaphor
can I have seven hundred million dollars
please or you got to go public one or
the other
IPO Susan mm-hmm you gotta get bought go
public go private again like Tesla get
bought again do it all again get fined
totally okay so those are the five
stories now it's time for TV recap I
have so much to recap today most of it
you've already seen so you can um let me
know your thoughts now all the stuff
that I missed
definitely season dead to me season two
ultimately so good I love the way it's
set up the end it's just like the first
season I love Ben and christina
applegate like I ship them so hard but
she murdered his brother what's the girl
gonna do I don't know that's the biggest
problem it's like they really mess with
you because you're so like you're their
number one champion like you just think
they both really need each other but she
did kill his brother like in cold blood
so that is calm blood it's not even like
Judi who accidentally killed her husband
so he can still be Christina's best
friend um I will say like every time I
was watching the show I just had like an
unidentified pit in my stomach it just
is very anxiety inducing like to put
yourself in those shoes of these women
who's like lives are about to come
crashing down around them and all I'm
thinking is like don't be suspicious
don't be suspicious it's lucious and so
it's it's pretty anxiety inducing but
it's a very well done show I cannot
stand Judy like she is a riptide and
ultimately like everything works out
because she's a good person but like
she's a [ __ ] yeah when she kept the
letter from Christina Applegate and hid
it under her bed so that kid could find
it and the kid reads I forgive you for
killing my husband the kid didn't know
that Judy was the one who killed his dad
like how dumb are you Judy burn the
evidence she's so so dumb it it's
honestly frustrating to watch um the
steena shut her mouth Christina is smart
enough for the both of them so it's not
like I'm just watching like dumb people
who
aren't going to the cops I think
ultimately the way it all turned out was
really great I'm glad that Christina got
away with it and for now it it was
enjoyable I it's a great show
yeah and honestly james marsden like
really looked so different he definitely
gain like 15 pounds but he grabbed his
hair and he like they looked like twins
obviously but they didn't look like the
same person
no like I wasn't thinking oh this Steve
know for a second I was like thank God
he's not dead okay of course but the
whole time I wasn't reminded of Steve I
was just say oh it's James Martin being
the lovable James Marsden that I love
yeah also I like loved the weird
flashback to when she went to City Hall
and the guy who tried to assault her in
his garage was like weirdly on the board
yeah that was weird um but I everything
was just coming full circle also Judy's
um new girlfriend I don't know the name
of the actress but I just like hyper
Perabo she looks like the girl from
coyote this time what I was gonna say oh
my god she was around me so much of Nora
from Cheaper by the Dozen oh no she was
in nine oh two one oh and she was so um
she was such a villain like she she was
so deceitful she like conned Liam I
forget exactly what she did but whenever
I see her face I'm like oh my god shits
going down like do not trust her but she
was she was trustworthy I didn't
remember what she did I just remembered
like do not trust her you just remember
feeling betrayed by her I did I did and
like Liam just justice for him you know
I'm so glad he watched it I started the
new season of drag race so I'm finally
all caught up with where we are now the
finale is on Friday so I really want to
get all caught I know like it's just
great timing but there's no much tea
this season like they now have a
disclaimer before every episode it's
like a little black and white statement
saying one of the contestants cherry pie
has been disqualified according to you
know a statement she released but out of
respect to the Queens and all the work
put into it we're still gonna air the
season as planned
um it's crazy because Cherie pie is
before I knew what she did like one of
my favorite drag one of my favorite
Queens like she's so talented she has
very witty smart like they all did like
a sports theme or like they all came out
looking like that's what layer's but she
came out looking like mr. hachoo bow
with her um javelin throw like she's
just like she's on she's my vibe but
turns out she's insane and we can't
stand her but so then I looked into it
cuz I'm like so delayed in all the drama
and basically when she got announced as
a cat's member there was a ton of
backlash like five or six people spoke
out saying we know this person um they
like pretended to be a casting director
and made us all like Skype with him and
send him weird videos get naked like
masturbate on camera and once that all
came to light mama ro was like
absolutely not and the introduces Damon
he's been disqualified but he's still a
part of the season like it's so weird
like he's getting judged but I think he
makes it really far um but he's just
irrelevant but he's so much airtime it's
like still frustrating to like give your
time and attention to this person who's
no longer part of the competition yeah I
remember when that happened but I didn't
realize it was a character who really
had so much potential Oh like he was top
five I mean I don't know how far he gets
because I'm only like four episodes in
but he definitely had the potential to
win damn I mean is the finale like later
than the rest of the show yeah they do a
live finale usually at the ACE theatre
in LA and it looks so fabulous they have
like a reunion they bring everyone back
it's live TV but it's my understanding
they're doing a virtual live according
to Michelle visage is Twitter that makes
sense well cool that's exciting for you
that you'll be all caught up in time for
the finale yeah like I just really want
to be a part of the dialogue you know
and it's annoying because it airs on
Friday so I'm gonna have to wait till
Mondays to like recap oh that is
annoying yeah what do you think about
Hollywood okay I ultimately loved it I
just when I watched half before I went
to sleep and then I just like woke up
thinking about it and just like invested
in the characters and what was gonna
happen and so I I love like from overall
I loved it of course I had issues with
it most of it being like and I realized
that we'd said on this show when we were
reporting that the show was coming out
we said that it was you know sort of
them I don't know there's a word for it
like fantastical like like well uh that
guy does cut Quint in Tarantino like
inglorious basterds yeah yes where
everything goes the way that he wanted
to go but there's a difference between
um saying that like Hitler was killed
during the war which everybody knows
that he was
versus this movie that comes out and
Hollywood's doing the right thing and
everyone's winning awards and I'm like
the whole time I'm like is was Megeve a
real movie are these real actors like
but I know that Rock Hudson is a real
person so they're using real historical
things and coupling them with you know
obviously elements utopian elements that
they want to be true but I think it's
like historically misleading because
hearing yeah I didn't do research
afterwards I would be like wow 1950s
Hollywood so progressive
but that's just not the case and so I'll
I love this show I really do think that
when you're gonna use some real people
and then make it not true there needs to
be a disclaimer at the end that explains
what actually happens like that Rock
Hudson lived in the closet his entire
career I assumed that he was out the
whole time until I until I moved into it
right so like unless you do your own
research and by the way you have to like
you have it's incumbent on some
publication to write up the truth
otherwise the magazine is where I read
it right so if they don't even do that
writing like how are we expected to know
what actually happened and I don't want
to remember history in a way that it
wasn't you know I want to enjoy his show
but like I don't want to think something
was better than it was you know right
and then a totally like tea legitimizes
the experience of like black Asian
female actors in Hollywood who worked
tirelessly for equality and still don't
have it
yeah it just I'm so I don't want to say
like I think the show overall is so good
and like if you understand the history
of Hollywood in and out and you know
that a movie named Meg was never made
with a a black writer starring a black
actress and they all won every cinematic
director write it so if you understand
the whole history and then you watch
that you're like wow it's it's you know
it's just like understanding World War
two and then watching inglorious
basterds it's like oh I wish but when
you don't know that much about it and
you're watching it and it's just you're
you know that some of the elements are
true so you don't know which ones aren't
true it's just not I just can't
I don't just don't think it's good to
remember things not as they were you
know and it's okay to like make a
utopian scenario but to not give context
at the end or hey I agree it was very
misleading I didn't realize that it was
quite possibly true until they changed
Roy's name to Rock Hudson up like oh
wait this is real
yeah and I know that some of it was
based on the book about the gas station
the gas station was real
I don't think ace pictures is a real
thing um a lot like I've never heard of
Jack Costello I don't think he's not a
real guy but you had to like do all this
research and which is fine I just some
people don't do the research and there
they are thinking like 1950s America
we're just giving out all these Academy
Awards to people of every different
background and that's just not true like
we the country wasn't that great no
totally it still isn't yeah so um I
agree that's a very very poignant
explanation but ultimately I absolutely
loved the show
I loved Laura Harrier I think she's so
absolutely stunning she was so beautiful
as Camille Washington the cast when she
won the Oscar I just the cat scene was
so on point I really once it got good
and it took a few episodes to get into
it I never wanted it to end and you know
I loved that it was all happy ending
happy ending happy ending because that's
all we ever really want but like not at
the expense of like the history yeah so
but I ultimately I loved it I'm so
excited for obviously season 2 or what's
gonna what what did they get greenlit is
it Susan - and like it felt like at the
anyway it opened it up her season two
because they had oh well they like
they're just he's medium in the movie oh
they're no no they were on set for in
the movie about the gas station because
cuz Archie's writing what he knows so
which would be like his story yeah yeah
it was just and it really they tied it
up at the end like everyone had a
partner like it was great yeah it was so
so cute Claire wood and jack costello
were like so cute and they actually
loved each other even though like hockey
mom and I you know I had honestly
forgotten that he [ __ ] her mom yeah
and I think it was okay yeah she said it
was okay I loved Avis Amburg Mego Patti
LuPone Rob Reiner came around I get so
confused between Patti LuPone and Patti
LaBelle is Patti LuPone okay yeah she
was icon iconic I
connick everything about it was so good
and I thoroughly enjoyed it then I watch
started season 4 of money heist and I
have to say maybe it's because I
accidentally skipped through the
previously on so I was a little lost but
that's the worst and they don't let you
go back there was no way I was like
reset I couldn't go back um but it's
just not as good as the other seasons
for some reason I don't know why yeah
it's good stealing you know it's it's
like a interesting story of like how
they're just gonna opt ox one another
and every time the professor comes up
with something or the the FBI comes up
with something it's always like they're
so smart um but it's just not as good oh
you know what else I watched there's
this documentary on Netflix I forget
what it's called it's all about
psychedelics and they get um like a ton
of celebrity sharing their experience
doing like mushrooms acid like LSD and
it's very funny and they have crazy
celebrities like they got Ben Stiller
sting um Anthony Bourdain and it was
really funny and it was like a New Wave
PSA about like drugs it's like they were
kept flashing backs like this is your
brain this is your brain on drugs but
actually like some psychedelics are used
in a lot of like clinical trials for
mental health and there's all this new
information on it and those people like
sharing their experiences and then also
giving tips I do not ever drive after
taking LSD like you will forget how to
drive try and stay out of the city don't
ever look in a mirror like it was very
very funny and very well done and I
imagine if you're watching it while on
psychedelics like the colors were crazy
like it was like all these like
kaleidoscope vibes and was made for
someone like on drugs and it was
actually really funny oh that's so cool
yeah so if you want to do drugs check it
out
nice well okay I feel thoroughly
recapped hopefully have a chance to
finish money high season for this week
but now that I'm like back in the
reading swing of things um we'll see I
also have so much to do today like you
could see I took the sheets off my bed
I gotta wash my sheets also for those
who have been following olivia is going
to be on new york one today talking
about her petition if you haven't signed
it yet it's in the morning toast
Instagram bio just fighting for the
rights of antepartum women so if
in New York check it out yes love it
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning shows the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as podcasts in our
podcast we found so it Spotify iTunes
stitcher public video I already asked
locks all the places whoever you listen
to podcast find someone you trust about
Serbia but a beautiful setting as far we
are we love you guys we'll see you
tomorrow fur Tuesday
see you tomorrow bye